est ce que tu te rappelles de gens de
pierre de genre de jean-pierre lula
alors c'est pas moi c'est pierre serre
oui oui il y en a plein je me rappelle
ça faisait ya longtemps c'est c est ce
que tu te rappelles d'un slot tu as
dansé avec un pire l'an 2000 à trappes
oula oula mondouzil dramé dossier de ce
les pierres massives doit dire oui
non mais tu avais 15 ans oui oui tu te
rappelles ou pas et ben pierre et là ce
soir
regardez bombe a fait leur entrée
maintenant tout le monde a compris notre
entrée pierre pierre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est alors shy'm avait des caméras
souple et chirac saint pierre est ce que
tu es content de voir pierre je sais
faire et donc ça c'est bon sens pourtant
jamais cessé
je sais que j'avais danse et un sous
ensemble pierre y allons et shy'm est ce
que vous voulez refaire ce chiot pour
nous ce soir
qu'est ce qui va nous mettre site et sur
quoi le slow c'est sûr msd sûrs et il a
eu qu'à loger ou pas arrête ça revenait
mois shy'm rené lapierre ne la mettez
vous leur mettez vous le mettez vous là
et c'est pas facile faut prévenir parce
que je sais à quoi ça vous fait plaisir
de le revoir
bah oui mais comme ça ici c'est des
armes s'il vous plaît crédits gérés
qu'avec valérie tout ça revenait la non
vous êtes lourds ils se sont isolés dans
m'arrêter moi je fais ça c'est quelque
chose à quoi je serais moi quand vous
êtes à l'été bull encore ses voitures a
dit je sais mettez vous là bas alors les
cherry est ce que vous voulez nous
refaire le selon aimé comme avant comme
à bonnart sur la liste même si j'aurais
demandé à didier marty de bien vouloir
mettre à nous remettre nos maîtres le
saut à paniquer mais c'est cette clause
est perdu on pense à les secourir
[Musique]
parce qu'ici
si on paie ah ouais
hier pierre chalard été dominés et shine
5 je vous sens il est venu de revoir
pierre ils pensent que moi je peux dire
quelque chose comme ça tu vas t'en
civile par non ils allaient alors pire
c'est quand votre nom de famille et puis
pierre il s'appelle comment est ce que
tu te rappelles de son nom de famille à
pierre mondy mais vous êtes sûr je vais
te buter
c'était cher je vais c'est quoi la paire
colada la mélanie vont rester là bas
eh ben je vais vous mettez pas la
sublime était avec moi non alors
mettez-vous la batterie
mettez vous là bas allaient nous mettez
vous mettez pas la table si vous ne
croyez pas les pierres que la saison
vient alors allez-y relance et aux
danses et une discours
sa sortie d'attenté mettez vous la
mettez vous devant le regard des métiers
je le regardais geoplin qu'elle y mettez
vous devant voilà vous êtes avec martin
sont marty voilà les cherry hill et
yoplait martic sks cyril je voulais dire
quelque chose six mois ça fait pas que
mercenaire il al'air chocolat
si on dit mais bisous
au jeu
je crée
c'est quoi
poursuivant son
pourtant
on me dit non
côté g20 dont le sommet
[Musique]